you uh did an incredible documentary on
safe Moon
uh the title is I uncovered a billion
dollar fraud uh can you tell me the
story of safe Moon sure so uh safe moon
was a crypto coin that exploded on the
scene in um
2021 I think at this point Sorry I'm
losing track of my years one year in
crypto is like five years in real life
um but it kind of gained a huge amount
of popularity because of this idea that
it's in the name you go safely to the
Moon how they were going to do this is
with sort of a sophisticated smart
contract idea where
there's I kind of have to explain the
way some contracts get rug pulled per
second or there's scams happen so in the
uh sometimes it's called like the [ __ ]
coin space the altcoin space anything
like below Bitcoin ethereum and maybe
the top five or ten is kind of seen as
this Wasteland of gambling and like you
know you don't know if they're the
developers are going to become anything
or not you're kind of like reading the
white paper trying to figure it out so
there's this big question about like how
can you get scammed how can back to the
interests you don't want the developer
to have some like parachute cord where
they can pull all the money out so one
way this happens is that in
decentralized decentralized finance
there's something called the liquidity
pool okay it's basically this big pot of
money that allows people to trade
between two different currencies so
let's say like safe Moon and Bitcoin
right or ethereum or it's actually on
the binance smart chain so it'd be BNB
um and this pool of money can be
controlled by the developers in such a
way they can steal it all right they can
just grab it I don't want to go too much
into details because I feel like I'll
lose people here but the point of safe
moon was the core idea was we're locking
this money up
you can't touch it and actually every
transaction that you buy safe moon with
will take a five percent tax of that
we'll do a 10 tax but five percent of it
will go back to all the holders of safe
Moon okay and five percent of it will go
back into this little pool of money okay
so the idea is as you trade as this
token becomes more viral
two things will happen one the people
who are holding it long term will be
rewarded for holding it long term by
receiving this five percent tax that's
distributed everyone and two you can
kind of trust that your your money's
gonna have this stable value because
this pool of money here in the middle
that's kind of guaranteeing you can get
your safe Moon out into this actually
valuable currency it's not going to move
so the story of safe moon was that
fundamentally this was not the case uh
they promised that this money was going
to be locked up it was not actually
locked up at all they said it was
automatically locked up you don't have
to worry about it well it was very
manually locked up and they didn't
actually lock a lot of it up
um they took a lot of it for themselves
for the developers so there's a lot of
players in this
um some of the a lot of them have left
by now there's kind of this main CEO
that everyone knows John caroni now and
You know despite saying that they were
going to lock up all the funds for four
years somehow he's gone from as everyone
else in the in the token has lost 99 of
the value of the token so they've lost
99 percent
he's gotten uh like a six million dollar
crypto portfolio multi-million dollar
real estate portfolio invested Millions
into various companies so he's he's
accrued this huge wealth and so I made a
video basically exposing that and
showing how this this coin which once
had a four billion dollar market cap is
just viral everywhere everyone was
talking about it because of these viral
ideas like it is sort of a captivating
idea that by holding it you could get
returns right like you just hold on to
it you automatically get money and it's
a viral idea that this money in the
middle in the pot isn't going to leave
you
when those things turned out to be false
this community has had a slow death as a
lot of people realized it was a scam and
there's been a core part of the
community
which gets to an interesting Dynamic we
can talk about if you want to
where they have like doubled down on the
belief in coroni and so part of it was
out of a hope to let those people know
what was really going on in their coin
and like hopefully save some of them
um
not like some altruistic sense but like
or not like some like I'm like a hero
sense but in the sense of um like I
think a lot of them didn't know like
literally didn't know so just sort of
like as a public service letting them
know so they could get their money out
and hopefully say themselves uh a lot of
pain and suffering so yeah they really
dug in so this is some did some did some
left I mean a lot of people have left
but the people who are left are people
with large amounts of safe Moon Holdings
that are down immensely and you can
imagine at a certain point in losses
there's a tremendous psychological
pressure to go look I'm I'm in it I
gotta go for the Long Haul and then you
want to believe that this thing is
legitimate and will succeed because a
there's an ego component around I
haven't been scammed I'm too smart to
get scammed it's tremendously uh you
know it hurts psychologically to
acknowledge you've been taken for a ride
and also you just want this thing to
succeed for your financial well-being so
you like want to believe it so there's
tremendous psychological pressure to
build cult-like communities around these
tokens
and I've noticed with the incentive of
like Community built it's sort of new to
finance there's like these meme coins or
these these Cults I don't want to it's
not really fair to call all of them
Colts like some of them are open to
criticism but one of the things that
defines Cults is they're not open to
sunlight or criticism
there's these Financial communities that
are opening up with crypto with a few
stocks where if you criticize them you
are attacked and the entire Community
has every incentive to kind of like
downplay your legitimate criticisms or
kind of
um
go after you and so it creates this
interesting Dynamic that's fascinated by